digamos que tenemos una cuerda por aquí
y tomamos el extremo izquierdo de la
cuerda y lo jalamos hacia arriba y luego
hacia abajo y bueno de lo que vamos a
hablar en este vídeo es de qué es lo que
pasa o de qué es lo que se forma con
esos movimientos y la cuerda entonces a
ver jalamos la cuerda hacia arriba y
entonces la cuerda se vería más o menos
de una forma de esta forma no porque a
la hora de jalar este extremo izquierdo
hacia arriba este pedazo de la cuerda va
a jalar a los pedazos a la derecha de
esta cuerda y va a terminar así ahora
qué es lo que pasa si después jalamos
ese mismo extremo hasta esta posición
otra vez pues los puntitos que están por
acá por ejemplo este puntito todavía
tiene un poco de inercia de cuando
calamos el extremo izquierdo hacia
arriba y el extremo izquierdo fue
jalando a los puntos de la derecha
entonces este puntito se va a seguir
moviendo hacia arriba definitivamente
con menos fuerza porque ahora la misma
cuerda los puntos hacia la izquierda de
esta cuerda lo van a estar jalando poco
a poco hacia abajo otra vez entonces
cómo se vería se vería más o menos
así
porque este puntito va a seguir
moviéndose por la inercia que trae de la
fuerza con la que estos puntos lo
jalaron hacia arriba y pues le va a
transmitir esa misma fuerza a todos los
puntos a la derecha de ese punto
entonces este punto va a estar jalando a
toda la cuerda hacia la derecha y si va
a ser con menos fuerza porque ahora
estos puntos van a empezar a jalar a
este punto hacia abajo bueno y ahora qué
pasa si jalamos el extremo izquierdo
todavía más hacia abajo y esta es sólo
una posición intermedia de cuando
jalamos la cuerda desde arriba hasta
abajo pero bueno lo que pasa es que a la
hora de que jalamos este extremo
izquierdo hasta abajo pues jala a los
puntos a la derecha de la cuerda y este
puntito recibe más fuerza que lo está
jalando hacia abajo entonces toda esa
inercia toda esa velocidad que llevaba
hacia arriba va a ser anulada por esta
nueva fuerza hacia abajo y va a cambiar
de dirección ahora va a tener inercia
hacia abajo porque le están jalando
hacia abajo y va a terminar como por acá
ahora lo que le pasa
este punto de aquí es lo mismo que le
estaba pasando a este punto cuando
estábamos por acá o sea este punto
estaba jalando a todos los puntos a la
derecha hacia arriba y como todavía no
llega a la fuerza hacia abajo de cuando
jalamos el extremo izquierdo hacia abajo
entonces ahorita solo tiene la inercia
hacia arriba de cuando este punto lo
estaba jalando hacia arriba entonces va
a seguir subiendo y va a jalar a todos
los puntos a la derecha de la cuerda y
la cuerda se va a ver más o menos así
y ahora vamos a regresar el extremo
izquierdo a su lugar original ok que
hablamos el extremo izquierdo desde
abajo hasta en medio entonces saber este
puntito lo están jalando hacia abajo y
tiene una inercia y una velocidad hacia
abajo y lo mismo le pasa a este o sea lo
están jalando hacia abajo y lo mismo le
pasa a este este puntito cuando acabamos
de jalar la cuerda hacia abajo estaba en
un punto en el que su inercia hacia
arriba se anulaba con la fuerza que
recibía hacia abajo y estaba justo ahí
pero si dejamos pasar un poquito de
tiempo como sigue recibiendo fuerza
hacia abajo entonces está siendo jalado
hacia abajo y termina por acá
y este punto estaba siendo jalado hacia
arriba por este punto entonces termina
por aquí y la cuerda se ve así
y ahora yo podría no mover más la cuerda
y que pasaría pues todo este pedazo de
cuerda tiene una inercia hacia arriba y
están jalando a este punto
entonces la cuerda va a terminar así
todo este pedazo de cuerda tiene una
inercia hacia abajo y están jalando a
este punto entonces este punto va a
terminar por acá pero este punto que lo
están jalando hacia acá va a escalar a
toda esta cuerda hacia arriba y de la
misma forma toda esta cuerda tiene una
inercia hacia abajo y están jalando este
punto y lo van a jalar hasta este punto
y este punto está jalando toda esta
cuerda hacia abajo también entonces van
a seguir con su inercia hacia abajo a
este punto acá lo están jalando hacia
arriba y va a terminar por acá y todo
este pedazo de cuerda lo va a jalar este
punto hacia abajo y este puntito está
jalando a toda la cuerda hacia arriba
entonces nuestra cuerda en este momento
se ve así
y si no hago nada más y no pierdo
energía por la fricción y por el calor
esta perturbación se va a seguir
moviendo a lo largo de la cuerda hacia
la derecha
y algún tiempo después mi cuerda se
vería de esta forma y si sigue
observando voy a seguir viendo que esta
perturbación esta perturbación sigue
moviéndose a la derecha y bueno le
empecé a llamar perturbación porque no
quería llamarle de entrada onda porque
que es una onda y bueno pues una onda un
ejemplo de una onda son justo estas
perturbaciones que se mueven a lo largo
de la cuerda así es que este es un
excelente momento para definir lo que es
una onda una onda es una perturbación
propagándose a lo largo del espacio
y bueno seguramente se van a encontrar
con muchas otras definiciones de lo que
una onda es por ejemplo una muy común es
que una onda es una perturbación
propagando energía a lo largo de un
medio pero qué es eso del medio pues por
ejemplo en este ejemplo de la cuerda la
misma cuerda es el medio ahora yo
prefiero usar esta definición porque más
adelante vamos a hablar de ondas
electromagnéticas y esas no se propagan
a lo largo de ningún medio se propagan a
través del vacío entonces pues para que
todo quede mejor vamos a usar esta
definición una onda es una perturbación
propagándose a lo largo del espacio y
bueno vamos a decir que generalmente
transfiere energía bueno ya que me
refiero con esto de que generalmente
transfiere energía pues si se fijan aquí
a la cuerda la jalamos hacia arriba
luego hacia abajo y otra vez de regreso
en medio y el resto de la cuerda se fue
jalando ella misma hacia arriba
y otra vez hacia el medio y si esperamos
suficiente tiempo y nos fijamos en un
punto por acá pues eventualmente esta
perturbación va a llegar a este punto y
la va a jalar hacia arriba y luego hacia
abajo y luego otra vez hacia el medio y
eso les va a pasar a todos los puntitos
a la derecha eventualmente los van a
jalar hacia arriba luego así en medio
hacia abajo y otra vez así en medio
entonces esta energía que yo le puse al
extremo de la izquierda de la cuerda de
jalarla hacia arriba luego así en medio
hacia abajo y luego otra vez hacia el
medio se está transfiriendo a cada uno
de los puntos de la cuerda a la derecha
si yo pusiera un objeto por aquí encima
de la cuerda cuando la onda llegar a
este punto lo haría saltar entonces está
transfiriendo la energía a lo largo de
la cuerda
en este caso ahora nuestra definición de
onda es muy amplia y este no es el único
tipo de ondas que existen o sea por
ejemplo también tenemos las ondas
sonoras o sea las ondas del sonido
veamos lo de las ondas del sonido o sea
por ejemplo tenemos una bocina y tenemos
aquí una superficie y por todos lados
pues hay partículas de aire
y bueno qué pasa si esta membrana de
repente se mueve a la derecha así como
por acá pues todas estas partículas que
están por acá van a terminar por acá no
y el aire en esta franja que está
inmediatamente a la derecha de donde
terminó la membrana está muy comprimido
todo está aquí hay muchísimas moléculas
de aire y cuando hay muchas moléculas de
aire muy apretadas se empiezan a repeler
entre sí y tratan de salir a donde
puedan por todos lados entonces estas
moléculas de aquí se están empujando
entre sí y entonces todos quieren salir
volando para todos lados pero claro como
la barrera está aquí pues todas las que
iban a salir volando para acá nada más
rebotan contra la pared pero todas estas
si van a imprimir una fuerza hacia la
derecha y van a empezar a aplastar a las
que están inmediatamente la derecha y
supongamos que ahora la membrana deja de
quedarse ahí y se regresa otra vez a su
lugar
así aquí antes ya no había partículas de
aire
y ahora la membrana regreso entonces
tampoco van a estar por aquí entonces
muchísimas de estas partículas de aire
salieron volando hacia la derecha y
ahora que ya no membrana a la izquierda
pues algunas de las que están aquí van a
volver a ocupar el espacio vacío pero
inmediatamente a la izquierda de toda
esta concentración inmensa de partículas
de aire pues como que hay menos
partículas y el chiste es que conforme
estas partículas van saliendo volando a
la derecha y empujando a otras
partículas pues el espacio no se queda
comprimido esto el espacio donde hay una
enorme concentración de partículas de
aire se va moviendo a la derecha de la
misma forma que en la onda sobre la
cuerda entonces si esta membrana vuelve
a repetir el movimiento y hacia la
derecha y a la izquierda varias veces y
dejamos pasar el tiempo esta área de
concentración de partículas de aire pues
se va a ir moviendo hacia la derecha y
si esta onda sigue moviéndose hacia la
derecha de la izquierda creando más
áreas de concentración de aire pues
eventualmente lo que vamos a ver
son varios espacios donde en un espacio
está no completamente vacío pero hay
menos partículas de aire inmediatamente
a la derecha hay una enorme
concentración de partículas de aire
a ver entonces la membrana se mueve a la
derecha y empuja a unas moléculas de
aire hacia la derecha formando un área
donde hay muchas moléculas de aire y
están como que comprimidas pero entonces
como están así esas moléculas de aire
que además tienen inercia de que las
movieron hacia la derecha pues van y les
pegan a otras moléculas justo las
moléculas que estaban como que por la
derecha y esas moléculas pues reciben
toda esa energía y pues empiezan a
pegarles a las de la derecha las cuales
van a seguir pegando a las de la derecha
y bueno al mismo tiempo la membrana se
regresa a su lugar y deja un espacio
vacío por acá que hablando a algunas de
las moléculas que ya había empujado sin
embargo muchas otras moléculas ya fueron
empujadas hacia la derecha y siguen
empujando a otras moléculas hacia la
derecha haciendo que haya áreas
comprimidas hacia la derecha y digamos
que el área comprimida donde hay muchas
moléculas de aire se vayan moviendo
hacia la derecha y siempre que hay un
espacio vacío un espacio con muy poca
concentración de moléculas de aire
a la a otras moléculas de aire entonces
al mismo tiempo están jalando a
moléculas hacia la izquierda entonces
toda esta área de baja concentración de
aire también se va a ir moviendo hacia
la derecha y la energía de la membrana
que se está moviendo hacia la derecha y
a la izquierda se está transfiriendo a
lo largo del aire hacia la derecha
entonces hemos generado una onda sonora
una onda de sonido ahora esta onda es
distinta de esta onda o sea siguiente la
dirección de la perturbación la
dirección de la onda es hacia la derecha
y hacia la izquierda que es el mismo eje
de dirección en el cual se está
propagando la onda o sea la onda se está
moviendo hacia la derecha y la onda su
dirección es ir en ese sentido hacia la
derecha de la izquierda a diferencia de
la cuerda donde la dirección de la onda
era hacia arriba y hacia abajo y la onda
se está propagando hacia la derecha
ahora a este tipo de ondas donde la
dirección de la onda es la misma que la
dirección en la cual se propaga la onda
le llamamos ondas longitudinales
bueno a este tipo de ondas también
llaman ondas de compresión porque se
provocan cuando el medio se comprime y
estas ondas se llaman ondas
transversales porque el medio se está
moviendo en una dirección que es
transversal perpendicular a la dirección
en la que está moviendo la onda o sea la
onda se mueve hacia la derecha pero el
medio o sea la cuerda se está moviendo
hacia abajo y hacia arriba que es una
dirección perpendicular o también
llamado transversal a la dirección de
derecha o izquierda ahora con respecto a
otra cosa en este ejemplo bueno a ver en
este ejemplo si hicimos que la membrana
se moverá hacia la derecha ya la
izquierda varias veces por lo menos aquí
están dibujados tres veces pero en este
ejemplo o sea nada más movimos el
extremo izquierdo de la cuerda una vez
hacia arriba luego en medio abajo y otra
vez arriba pero no volvemos a subir
entonces podríamos decir que hicimos una
sola perturbación esta perturbación
y el resto de la cuerda se mantenía en
estado de reposo a una sola de estas
perturbaciones le llamamos pulso y vamos
a necesitar más espacio si es que hay
que borrar esto entonces una sola de
estas perturbaciones es un pulso ahora
qué pasaría si en el ejemplo de la
cuerda subimos bajamos volvemos en medio
y inmediatamente después volvemos a
subir ya volver a hacerlo todo pues
nuestra onda se vería algo así como
bueno me quedo muy chica porque todas
estas deberían ser de la misma altura
pero creo que es suficiente entonces en
esta onda la primera vez que subimos el
extremo izquierdo de la cuerda hasta
arriba genera este pedazo de la onda que
se transmite a lo largo de la cuerda
hasta llegar a este punto y luego la
bajamos y esta energía se va
transmitiendo por la cuerda y hasta que
hace que este punto caiga por acá porque
y luego lo volvemos a llevar la cuerda
hasta el medio y después volvimos a
dejarla la cuerda hacia arriba y hacia
abajo y otra vez así en medio dándole
toda esa energía a la cuerda como para
que se siga moviendo y se formen todas
estas ondas
estar acá es mi pulso y lo estamos
repitiendo muchas veces
exactamente de la misma forma bueno a
este tipo de ondas se le llama ondas
periódicas y en el próximo vídeo vamos a
hablar un montón de las ondas periódicas
vamos a ver un montón de propiedades que
tienen como por ejemplo cómo se
relacionan su longitud de onda y su
frecuencia y su periodo con la velocidad
de la onda pero todo eso vamos a dejarlo
para el próximo vídeo y regresemos a lo
que teníamos antes bueno algo que quiero
que veas es que esta noción de onda es
una noción muy abstracta o sea las ondas
son un concepto que usamos todos los
días en cualquier concepto las zonas del
sonido un montón de cosas no pero o sea
estas ondas son muy abstractas son
simplemente una perturbación que
generalmente se transmite a lo largo de
un medio aunque a veces ni siquiera se
transmiten a través de un medio por
ejemplo las ondas electromagnéticas se
propagan a través del vacío y bueno
estas perturbaciones que son la esencia
de las ondas pueden tomar muchas formas
puede verse el movimiento del medio
pueden ser ondas transversales donde se
ve claramente que el medio se mueve o
pueden simplemente ser un cambio en la
concentración de moléculas de aire en el
espacio
y en el fondo si hay una relación o sea
por ejemplo si quisiéramos graficar
matemáticamente la densidad de moléculas
de aire en el espacio por ejemplo esta
línea recta sería cuando las moléculas
no han sido perturbadas y hay la misma
densidad en todo el espacio y en este
eje colocamos la densidad de moléculas
de aire que hay en el espacio y gráfica
damos por ejemplo aquí hay una densidad
muy alta entonces digamos que está por
acá y aquí hay una densidad muy baja
entonces al estar por como por acá
entonces podemos graficar la densidad y
nos quedaría algo así
entonces esta gráfica lo que representa
es la densidad de moléculas de aire que
hay
estas franjas de aire que hay por aquí y
si se fijan estas gráficas se parecen
mucho a las ondas transversales sobre la
cuerda y por eso lo agrupan todo dentro
de ondas porque matemáticamente son muy
parecidas aunque físicamente se vean tan
distintas tienes esta cantidad que va
variando y que además se va
transportando hacia la derecha sobre un
medio o sobre el espacio en este caso
esa cantidad es la densidad de moléculas
de aire en una franja o un espacio y en
este caso es la altura de la cuerda y
bueno son tan parecidas que agrupan
estos dos tipos de fenómenos en un solo
concepto que es el concepto de onda y
bueno te veo en el próximo vídeo